so what does this gospel say well in a
general sense we could categorize it as
a kind of esoteric text or at least a
text concerned with esotericism and
esoteric doctrines there's a kind of
dichotomy presented between those who
are in the no so to say the ones that
have access to the true doctrines and
interpretations of the Bible the in
group in this case and the other the
apostolic Christians who are misled and
misinterpret scripture and Jesus by
reading things too literally this other
quote unquote misled group clearly
represents the so-called Proto Orthodox
who are misappropriating the message of
Jesus they are even referred to in a
derogatory way as Hebrews in the text